the first trailer for thor ragnarok is
dropped and for less than two minutes of
footage it's positively loaded with
intel on Marvel's latest project from
how the Incredible Hulk fits into all
this to the new Big Bad it looks to take
out all of Asgard on her own here's
everything we learned from the first
door Ragnarok trailer and why we think
this film will almost certainly blow us
all away when it drops on November 3rd
hella is hella powerful outside of Loki
villains have almost always been the
weak point across the MCU after the
fairly boring Dark Elves in the dark
world Marvel is looking to up the ante
in a big way with the villain and
Ragnarok Cate Blanchet is playing
Marvel's Norse goddess hella and she
more than lives up to the title we get
our first look at hella here and she is
positively terrifying Blanchett looks
plenty intimidating in the role as Thor
and the full might of Asgard looks to be
no match for her destructive
capabilities mule nor destroyed
Thor's weapon of choice has been a key
piece of the MCU since we first got a
peek at Coulson and his shield team
trying to mine it out of the ground in
Iron Man twos post-credit scene but all
that ends here
Thor tries to take on hella with a
trademark throw of Mjolnir but she's
powerful enough to stop at midair worse
she also crushes it into charged little
hammer bits meaning Thor is officially
hammerless more hammer time y'all
considering the big deal that's been
made about this hammer and how no one
can lift it or in this case hold it
without being worthy it makes one wonder
just how powerful hella might actually
be that hammer has always been one of
the most powerful objects in the MCU and
it was just turned into a scrap heap
Asgard is dead we see hella faceoff with
a whole of Asgard's army on her own
shortly before fire engulfs the entire
city hella makes the point even clearer
with her line
instead we've seen Asgard face its fair
share of damage and the other Thor films
we've never seen the city of the gods
actually wiped out the events here could
have a lasting impact on the MCU
especially if it means there are a lot
of displaced Norse gods just roaming the
galaxy the new faces from Robert Redford
and Captain America the Winter Soldier
to Glenn Close in guardians of the
galaxy the MCU has been attracting its
fair share of a list actors over the
past few years now it's time for
Jurassic Park alum Jeff Goldblum to make
the jump into the Marvel Universe here
golden plays the Grand Master who seems
to be pulling the strings of the
super-powered gladiatorial games where
Thor finds himself after being captured
Goldblum looks amazing in his costume
and this looks to be one of the most
colorful Marvel films today the footage
here also gives us our first good look
at Creed alum Tessa Thompson an
Asgardian warrior who seems to be
working for the Grandmaster Valkyrie
will serve as a potential love interest
for Thor with Natalie Portman's Jane
Foster off the board judging by what we
see over here it'll be interesting to
see how her allegiances are tested along
the way and finally Karl Urban takes on
the role of scourge the executioner in
one of the coolest shoutouts to Thor's
comic book past that we've seen on
screen when you see this the filmmakers
are reminding you of the Mighty Thor
number 362 in that issue which comes
from the legendary story arc by Walt
Simonson in the 80s the executioner
holds off the hordes of hell with a
couple of machine guns and his pure
unfiltered rage karl Urban's already a
comics to film legend for his role in
Dredd chances seem good he'll go down in
history for doing the executioner
justice to Loki's back when we last left
Loki he was the secret king of Asgard
having assumed Odin's form at the end of
the dark world but we stand back in his
Tom Hiddleston face here wielding a few
knives during a fight scene Loki shows
up a bit later sitting with a
grandmaster and watching Thor's fight
with the Hulk
so is Loki pulling the strings to keep
Thor locked up be there to rescue him is
he there to just enjoy the show you
can't wait to find out Heimdall goes
rogue Idris Elba's Heimdall has been a
quiet force in all the Thor movies
guarding the Bifrost and generally being
a legit badass but he loses the fancy
armor and finds himself flying solo in
Ragnarok
the brief shot of heimdal we see here
shows him looking very much like scruffy
idris elba
but he's still building that sword and
mowing down bad guys as needed we've
never really seen Heimdall out on his
own seemingly without a Bifrost to
defend will he eventually join up with
Thor to try to retake Asgard Thor and
Hulk reunited as expected the best
moment is when we finally get a look at
Mark Ruffalo's Hulk in full-on World War
Hulk attire ready to take on all comers
in the gladiator rank yeah we felt the
same way door we still don't know
exactly how Hulk ended up in deep space
or why he seems keen to start whaling on
Thor but this is the first setup of the
weirdest budding movie we never knew we
wanted to see they borrowed star Lords
walkman guardians of the galaxy set the
tone for the MCU in regards to how
popular music can be used to sell a
story and it seems thor ragnarok
borrowed a cassette or two from Star
Lords tape deck the entire trailer is
set to the rocking beats of Led
Zeppelin's immigrant song and combined
with the neon colors and font folk
straight out of Star Trek to the Wrath
of Khan
it sets a tone unlike any Thor movie
we've seen before and it looks like the
most fun they've had in Asgard in ages
well you know except for all the
destruction in style thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
the school stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]